let's do a random challenge Oh also if
you're new here Luke Luke read 21
welcome to the stream if you're if
you're new here say hi or don't say hi
but hopefully other people will say hi
yeah I know I know they're working on
the cover I think it's gonna be a really
cool cover I don't know if it won't be
just my entire face covering the cover
but I mean covers are meant to be
covered also accident from Florida
welcome back thanks for subbing for five
months London time what's up Liam's
London I feel like I've exhausted like
so many so many opening ideas okay so my
opponents what country is this from
Philippines has not watched my video on
the dirty London trap they h5e five
winning guaranteed so when to win a
piece after three moves you got
discovered this when working with the
students my student encountered this as
white we miss you an opponent played
aged five but didn't play e5 and then
looking back we discovered ePHI with
engine your Boise man welcome back
thanks for subbing for four months so
now my opponents of the flustered the
idea for the for those who haven't seen
this before the idea is this Bishop
because getting trapped after a vision
of g3 h4 chops a bishop if Bishop takes
e5 there was f6 g5h for so it's kind of
sad for whites but my my opponents
sadness is my happiness
kind of pink Jake welcome back yeah
welcome back everyone Brian welcome back
let's develop a rook why not maybe I'll
rook lift I think before I vaguely
remember a game where my opponents I had
this exact same position my opponent
like allowed this and this and then
resigned off to find that I don't think
I put it on YouTube or maybe I did I
don't know
whoa it's just me me think chefs weed
reading with 66 okay let's um let's lift
her up if you're just joining from chess
we'd stream my appoint foul will do a
slow-motion replay fell for the dirty H
5 London trap h5e 3 is a blunder and on
e5 wins the piece for black it's a
beautiful beautiful creation yeah shout
out to the weed we have a weave command
also Thank You Lauren like on subbing
for 2 months no did I botch that the e
key is weird on my my keyboard where
I'll press it once and I'll do a lot of
ease okay it's time for a pin and win
and maybe the pin will lead to some kind
of fork
rook the rook what do we call this
migrated immigrated immigrated from h8
to be to Fein cuddling in the pawns
territory I probably want to move it
back and I am so glad you're back
mr. streams 16 months of great content
oh thanks so much unlimited rice pudding
I went grocery shopping earlier I forgot
to value rice pudding I bought cottage
cheese that's close enough
let's play yg4 get the other bishop into
the game oh thanks I missed you too yeah
I think so many people in a while thank
you
only rice pudding gifting a sub to chest
weed and the Lord Francisco I got
confused oh it's just a blue
I miss you too son
let's um let's take a thing I have three
pieces in weights territory
I think 21 months that's yeah that's how
it works I guess on Twitch you have so
many children okay yeah I guess adopted
I guess a lot of people over the years
and you'll welcome back I notice I
notice people znation chess was easy
nation chess has been one of the founder
of the channel maybe the only founder
not sure oh no one of the one of a few
founders I think exercise sparks is
another founder I really got to update
the sub badges I could take a look but I
think the the bishop is more valuable
than the rook I think the plan is this
and then that maybe I'll take the rook
all about getting to at least one of the
meeting squares Oh a point wants to turn
me do i sack a night or do I
let's save the night chess Bay how's it
going welcome back so many yeah so many
people here get to see some mods some
some new people some jaws Auto something
for two months take a thing
yeah this opening works quite well the
thing is like my opponents everyone
tried to play sabe but yeah suffered
some trying to put this in a nice way I
just suffered from from from some dirty
opening tricks I'll go back and show
what what could be improved also this is
this is a move to to make Ben happy
always played this before you Eric
oh thanks so much yeah thank you kind of
pick Jake kind of pink Jake it's hard to
say quickly something for five months
Kingston for 16 months yeah I could game
to my opponents oh people discussing I
swear I had this exact position before
where I think this was a game and my
opponent resigned but let's check it oh
me just out of base maybe not I have
this position before I guess not but
yeah every London player should be aware
of this hmm oh the super noodles super
noodles Oh cuz it's July yeah Oh me like
just over a week I think um thank you
thanks everyone so okay but let me um
let me just show what can be improved
and really like this opening for black
should be used just in blitz and bullets
and not really in classical chests Oh
Pam welcome back how's it going Pam
good to see you oh good to see you bits
first I thought that said good to see
you in bits but yeah good to see you
bits are are much appreciated so yeah I
think like if you know why it's gonna
play III next move h5 is one of the the
dirtiest approaches as yeah like can't
save the piece here with g5 coming and
here the best line for white is to take
with a bishop and then after this at
some point white should play vision d3
and get in Bishop g2 it's still better
for black well yeah Oh provoke g5 and
then 92 also yeah Bishop d3 is
interesting actually because then the
King has to move I mean like coming this
pawn but next time if you're white and
black plays h5 Knight f3 or even c4
computer like c4 if you want to stick
with a London just 9 f3 and then you
control a 5 and g5 and then later you
can play e3 anyway uh hello to more
people